the endometrium is the inside lining of
the uterus an endometrial biopsy is the
removal of a sample of tissue from the
endometrium for testing a biopsy may be
done to screen for cancer or
precancerous cells to determine the
cause of irregular bleeding or to
investigate fertility problems this
procedure can also check for infections
and monitor the effectiveness of certain
medications an endometrial biopsy can be
done in your doctor's office in 10 to 15
minutes without the use of a sedative
your doctor will first do a manual exam
to determine the position of your uterus
and then place a speculum in your vagina
to open it up and keep it open so the
cervix is visible your doctor may use
another instrument called a tenaculum to
grasp the cervix and hold it steady
during the procedure your doctor will
then pass a long thin flexible tube
called a pipe health through your vagina
and cervix and into your uterus the pipe
L is equipped with a piston like device
that creates suction when pulled your
doctor will spin the pipe l and move it
up and down in the uterus while
suctioning up an adequate sample of
endometrial tissue then remove the pipe
L and place its contents in a container
your doctor will complete the procedure
by removing the tenaculum and speculum
after the biopsy some patients are able
to sit up immediately and feel minimal
cramping others who may feel some
dizziness will be asked to lie still for
about 10 to 15 minutes before being
released an anti-inflammatory medication
such as ibuprofen or naproxen is often
prescribed to minimize any menstrual
like cramping or discomfort your doctor
will send the sample to the lab for
testing results may be given to you by
telephone or during a follow-up
appointment with your physician